Also this morning, a frantic
search is underway
at an apartment
complex in Dnipro, Ukraine,
as it is growing more frantic.
Search teams now say they don't
to find any more survivors
at the scene of the strike
that has killed so far.
At least 44 people,
including four children.
Rescuers have already pulled
several survivors out
since the weekend attack,
but almost all of the wreckage
has now been dismantled.
Yet still. 25 residents are miss
The first lady of Ukraine
has slammed the Russians
for one of the worst
attacks on civilians.
Since the war began.
In a speech that she just delive
at the World Economic Forum in D
These people, ordinary people
at home on a Saturday,
and that's enough reason for Rus
to kill the war.
There is nothing off limits for
as we speak.
In our city of Dnipro.
Our people are still working and
and sorting
through the debris
of a residential area of a house
that was destroyed
or it destroyed by an anti-ship
This missile was built to destro
aircraft carriers
and was used
against the civilian infrastruct
Ukrainian officials
say that
a Russian catch 22
missile was used in that strike.
It is designated to take out
aircraft carriers, typically
So joining us now to talk about
this is retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons.
I mean, this is a weapon
that is notoriously inaccurate
and is designed to hit large spa
And so what do you make of the i
that here it is
targeting this apartment complex
where all these people were livi
let's say,
a weapon from the old Cold War?
It's designed,
like I
said, to hit
those naval aircraft carriers
because it attacks from a high a
And the problem Ukraine has with
that is they can't detect it.
There's no early
warning systems right now.
But that doesn't matter to Russi
Russia is using it as a weapon o
All they have to do
is put it close
to any of these built up areas,
knowing it will hit something
in this case,
unfortunately, at that
apartment building. Yeah.
And so when you say delivered at
altitude, is the sense of
how does this kind of thing hit?
Because I was reading about this
and they were saying that why
it can cause so much damage
is the way that it strikes.
Let me show you on the map here
what happens is backfire.
Bombers come from from Russia
here and come into the Black Sea
And what happens is
it's about a 400 mile range
and at about 30,000
feet at a very high altitude,
it releases its missile.
And then it
comes down in this direction her
and then.
So any of these
any of these cities here along
that coastline
are threatened
by this kind of weapon system
because any of the early warning
that Ukraine has can't pick it u
from that level of altitude.
Is the sense
that they were even actually aim
for this apartment complex
or were they just
aiming for the Dnipro area?
Generally, they were.
They were just hitting that main
built up area,
using it as a weapon of terror.
This is all technology.
But again,
they don't have it flies
at supersonic speed.
Ukraine doesn't have anything
from an early warning
detection perspective,
which raises questions
about what they do happen
or the United States is talking
is obviously sending that one
Patriot missile defense system.
But it seems like
that is just really a drop in th
that they would need much more
than just that one system to com
That's right. They need five or
If you had a Patriot battery
in any of these areas here,
it would protect all on
this coastline into Odessa.
Make sure that any of these earl
warning systems that are coming
are 400 miles or so away
would at least have a chance.
Right now,
one Patriot
battery likely just protects Kie
and that's it.
But any of these other built up
are going to be
unfortunately exposed
to this kind of terror weapon.
So this is clearly a case
that they do need more.
I think that's what
the Ukraine defense minister was
when they said
we don't have the capability to
because of that standoff.
The Russians have the capability
to fire this at a standoff dista
that they can defend it.
But this is former CIA
chief of Russia Operation
Steve Hall to a piano was saying
there there
all these meetings around the wo
they're talking about it in Davo
They're talking about it
in Washington today.
The U.S.
has got a delegation in Kiev tod
shoring up support of one kind
or another for Ukraine.
Well,
why is there a sense that it nee
shoring up?
And to be honest point is
that enough is just the status q
enough at this point for Ukraine
Well, John, I think
what this is reflective of,
when you hear
all of these countries leaders,
whether it's at Davos
or elsewhere,
say, look, we need to do somethi
we need to continue to shore up
our support
is because they understand that
this is Russia's plan.
Russia's plan is to wait
until that resolve,
until the idea of supporting
Ukraine either becomes too diffi
for countries
to do for economic reasons perha
or we simply lose focus
because, you know,
we're looking at, you know,
whatever the next crisis is.
And so that's what Russia's plan
You know, I agree.
We're we're not
we're a long way from the end of
We're not finished with this yet
And it's going to be a long time
And if we're going to continue
to support Ukraine, as we should
going to take continued resolve.
And I think that's what's going
when you hear these leaders
speak as they do.
Yeah.
And meantime,
Russia and Putin are still buyin
time, regrouping.
They conscripted about
300,000 soldiers in the fall.
There are expectations
that you could see
as many as an additional one
and a half million men
conscripted in the months ahead.
And what's interesting Steve,
is that Ukrainian intelligence
says that they believe
Vladimir Putin
wants to make another stab at Ki
in the coming months.
And given
where we were a year ago
with Ukraine saying
that's not going to happen
and the United States intelligen
saying
this is exactly what Vladimir Pu
to do a year later.
Do your sources in Intel
see the same things
that Ukrainian intel
is saying that Vladimir Putin
actually wants to go after Kiev
You know, from an analytic persp
it seems to make sense, right?
I mean, Putin really
doesn't have any options at this
What is he going to do to say, w
it didn't work,
let's go ahead and pull everybod
and go home?
No, that's not what he's going t
And it's
certainly not the way
the Russians fight wars.
The Russians
fight wars
by compensating
lack of quality for inserting qu
which is why you're seeing
more conscripts
that are going to be pulled up
and basically sent
ill prepared
into battle,
as many of the former
guys were
when they were pulled out of jai
I think the Ukrainian
first lady got it exactly right
when she said, look,
we're fighting for the world
as we know it
because we're talking about the
to just
to allow Russia or any country
just to run into another country
annexed portions of it,
not not obey international law.
That's what
that's what's really going on in
That's what we're fighting for.
And that's why the West is invol
because it does threaten
the international border.
What change is the balance
on the ground there?
There are these tanks.
Everyone's excited
about the possibility of the UK
sending, what, 12 to a dozen tan
Poland's talking about
sending some leopards
that are made in Germany.
What kind of a difference
would that make in the numbers
that they're actually talking ab
My understanding
is, is
that, you know, the number of ta
that the Brits are talking about
or even if you start
pulling other nations
as to what heavy armor
they're going to send,
won't make a whole
lot of a whole lot of difference
immediately on the ground.
But the thing is that
this is like a tide.
I mean, this is not something
that changes overnight.
These are, you know, big
military operations
big military weaponry,
lots of training involved.
So the whole thing is going to t
And so that's what West
the West is trying to ramp up
while Russia is saying,
okay, you guys ramp
up, we're going to continue
to play for the long run
and just continue to contribute.
You know, human
beings, Russians
to die in front of these,
it's just going to take time
to work itself out.
It's going to be a long time, I
Yeah, a long time.
Meantime, we had Vladimir Putin
sort of touting how resilient
the economy in Russia has been
this past year.
It's declined about three, three
and a half percent.
Early estimates were
were in the range of 10%.
So given all the sanctions
that have already been leveled
against Russia,
what more can be done
for the Kremlin
to finally say
this is too painful,
despite all of the dead troops
we have, it's too painful for
us economically to continue
Well, really beyond
what else is he going to say?
Is he going to say, you know wha
these sanctions
are really hitting us hard, but
3%? I think not.
I think what's going to happen.
Well, I think
I think it is having an impact.
And I think it's up to Putin
on his own airwaves
to try to convince Russians
who are saying,
wait a minute,
things aren't going so well.
To say, no, no, no,
everything is everything is fine
So there's going to
you're going to continue
to see this propaganda,
which is, you know, stock and tr
for Vladimir Putin.
But I think it is having an effe
And if Russia is going to be in
for the long run,
those sanctions have to continue
because they continue to bite
harder, harder and harder expone
as time goes on.
Steve Hall, great to see you.
Thank you so much for the analys